it's become the biggest shopping day of
the year Shoppers across the world flock
online to Amazon to get a Black Friday
bargain Bargains that Amazon workers say
come at a cost
everybody's looking for bargains here
but quite honestly these Bargains are
made on the backs of our colleagues they
just don't earn enough money for it
last year Amazon said it made a record
profit during the Black Friday weekend
but workers say that money isn't
trickling down they're walking off the
job to demand better working conditions
and better wages as inflation hits an
all-time high
with the small amount of money or salary
that you earn you can't live in this
time I have three children and we both
work and we have a huge problem because
the costs have risen so enormously that
you can't live with what you earned the
May Kim is on pay campaign is also
demanding that workers be able to
unionize and is calling for an end to
binding Collective agreements it's being
supported by environmental groups who
are calling on the company to commit to
environmental sustainability the most
serious industrial action has been
centered on the U.S France and Germany
with other protests planned across the
globe
we have 35 countries in the world asking
the same thing as us because Amazon is a
global company and we all have the same
working conditions and the same pay
which is at the lowest level of what
countries are allowed to pay we are all
in the same mess
Amazon has a patchy record when it comes
to workers rights last week a U.S
federal judge ordered the company to
stop retaliating against employees
engaged in workplace activism and in
2021 union leaders said that nearly half
of all injuries recorded in U.S
warehouses occurred at Amazon Amazon
workers all over the world no matter in
which country everything lives and work
are experiencing the same dehumanizing
mistreatment from Amazon the conditions
are so bad working for Amazon that there
is a turnover rate of 150 percent a year
Amazon sees the strikes won't affect
operations this weekend operations that
are set to net billions of dollars in
profit Alex beard Al Jazeera